hello everyone description and the first
reaction when I came here it was wow
this is such a long topic like such a
long title so don't worry I will unpack
I'll try to unpack this thing
it's basically evaluation of the cloud
hosting framework for machine learning
based equipment monitoring and each of
these words signifying as a company like
what I do
what industrial space that we are in and
why this is kind of relevant to us so we
kind of connect cloud-based services
like this topic will connect cloud-based
services are kind of a domain expertise
and industrial equipment monitoring and
this is more like a experience of sort
so if we were to use a cloud-based
services we have so many options out
there like a CEO GCP AWS then if you
were to make model saw develop models
which framework is kind of the most apt
for us so what I do I am data scientist
at arundo BIA based in Houston we are a
growing company of 100 and we basically
provide practical software solutions
towards industrial equipments monitoring
equipment monitoring and provide
enterprise scale machine learning
solutions through analytics and why this
topic so as a data scientist sorry so
the data scientist it is so it often
happens that the machine learning
solutions that we make are increasingly
becoming prevalent in this space of in
Delhi heavy asset industries so imagine
that you have these industries like
chemical processes chemical plants and
maritime ships and etc and there are
these large equipments that are kind of
expensive and it is very important that
we conduct we can capture if anything is
going wrong well in advance and innovate
to do that there are these sensors that
are attached to ad IOT sensors that
continuously stream data to us and our
goal is to develop solutions around it
and once we develop solutions in-house
and this has to be provided to our end
customers who can invoke this and can
basically act upon it
effectively so the question then becomes
for a data scientist how easy is it to
prediction eyes these machine learning
solutions that we have developed
in-house and for specific use cases
around equipment monitoring which is
time series based streaming data that we
we are getting continuously so the
outline would be that first I will talk
about what is the part to production for
the skill set that is perceived to be of
a data scientist and then I'll go on
towards machine learning for equipment
monitoring in AVS at industries like
specifically constraining that what are
the problems that we face of occurring
what kind of data that we face for
equipment monitoring and I'll give an
illustration example where we will try
to solve a particular we will try to
deploy a particular model which is
called prediction of anomalous
temperatures in alternating winding coil
so alternator is a device where you have
three say sensors attached to it inside
and there is rotating equipment and they
are capturing temperature continuously
and we are getting the temperature field
the question is when does something go
wrong in that alternator and anomaly
stands if something is going wrong now
we will be comparing three cloud-based
services and there's a reason why we do
these three and they are GCP as you are
an AWS and we will have three different
deployment scenarios so just to get a
gauge of what kind of audience this is
like how many of you actively do machine
learning deploy machine learning
solutions on any of these cloud services
okay good
so for people who wish to like start if
they think that which service they would
like to proceed with which they like to
adopt this is also like a presentation
of those sorts where these are like our
experience and it can be like a good
starting point for you guys also to see
where to start to if you were to use
these kinds of services so we have three
different deployment scenarios when we
are done developing machine solutions
and Python we typically use these
scikit-learn packages too which helps us
to develop these models
and we will slowly build customizations
on the scikit-learn package by attaching
some data processing steps before and
after this kind of a model prediction
stage and the question then becomes if
as an organization you are building more
and more sophisticated algorithms and
packages do these cloud services still
cater to your needs and if they do which
one is the best and which one is
probably controversially the worst and
then we will have the remarks so first
one I will go into the part two
production for data scientist so this is
where I think a chart where we see that
if we were in the left hand side which
is if you are a data scientist and you
make a machine learning models you'll
use services like a resistance a flow PI
Taj etcetera now the when question
becomes that if we were to productionize
this we need to get into the
nitty-gritty stuff of ok the environment
in which we are making our models should
be the same as the one that will be
deployed to and next then it becomes ok
we might have to use docker so that
these everything remains consistent with
the engineering code as well and so on
and so slowly we find that what we
started off we kind of go out of a
comfort zone if we are if we do not have
these skills and then you go towards
machine learning and then slowly to
DevOps so the question then becomes is
it possible to stay in this regime
around this and then still be able to
deliver value or deploy models easily do
C do these cloud providers expose these
high-level APRs to us or not so next I
will briefly talk about machine learning
for equipment monitoring in heavy asset
industry so this is typically a
pictorial representation that we have
these equipments that have sensors
attached to it that is streaming us data
we have we process the data because
assuming that if equipment is
transmitting at some frequency but we
want at a different frequency then we
kind of do some pre-processing and
frequency is just one kind of an example
of pre-processing there can be many
other kinds of pre-processing
model predict is basically whatever
there is this black box or model where
this data comes in this pre-processed
data and you do some kind of a
prediction outside
now these predicted values itself cannot
it not necessarily be usable and to do
some kind of a post-processing and then
you map it to something which is say
meaningful so this is really helpful
because if you are caring if there is
some issue or some problems that are go
into encounter in this equipment you can
capture it well in advance now so this
the data that we are going to deal with
typically is the time series data and
that is this thing called tags they call
it tags are nothing but actual the
columns actual data that we are
receiving they can be like temperature
pressure these are some physical
quantities in an equipment also one
thing that we see in our organization is
that typically we just don't receive
this data and just do this problem that
is some attached subject matter expert
input as well and because being
necessarily as data scientist we do not
belong in that domain and we need some
kind of an input that can aid us make
better models and this subject matter
expert can also we are in a scenario
where we can affect our modeling
decisions so now there are some
important logistics in this area of
heavy acid which is that privacy is
actually a critical concern for our
customers because this we are talking
about customers in oil and gas
it's a try and it is we have found it is
super important for them so it is really
important that if we are choosing a
cloud provider service then they have a
reputed high reputation in terms of
security and compliance in in those
similar aspects now one thing also is
important to mind that once you start
making solutions if your customer is
already associated with some kind of
existing cloud solutions then you have
to be kind of compatible with them so
that's why it's kind of an important
thing that if you were picking off one
of these off-the-shelf providers cloud
providers how what are the pitfalls you
can
encounter so next I will say about the
illustration which is a predict
anomalous so I'll talk about the
modeling part of this equipment
monitoring based solution now let's take
this example where we have this three
temperature sensors in a coil in an
alternator and the x-axis is time so we
have like two weeks worth of data and
the y-axis is a temperature now the
question is predict whether when an
alternative winding coil would
experience abnormal temperatures and as
we can clearly see in this kind of data
towards the end of the second week the
coil through the Green the coil in the
green color is clearly not behaving well
now without getting into too much of the
modeling part because I want to talk
about the deployment aspect of it let's
just assume that we make this model and
people who are interested in knowing
about how we make this model like we can
talk offline but the models that we
eventually use this is called a
regression based anomaly detection in
high-level terms it basically means that
there are these three coils or these
three sensor values that are going in
sync with each other you are trying to
map the correlation of one sensor value
with respect to the other coils and as
soon as that correlation breaks that is
you have to flag that that's problematic
for us so it's a very that's why it's
called a regression based anomaly
detection you will regress one sensor
one temperature on the other two now we
get into this pipeline of remember I
showed you like there was a
pre-processing step there's a model
prediction step and as a post-processing
we can kind of unpack that into this
particular workflow like assume that we
are getting a one minute data from this
particular equipment and we need to do
some pre-processing in this case it is
resampling and then we do a prediction
of where at this given point of time is
it anomalous or not and then we go into
some post-processing where we say that
we compute the residuals of the studio's
basically means that what I have
predicted the temperature should be this
but now the actual
pressure coin is this so how far apart
are we and then we proceed with some
more post-processing and then we map it
to our final say 0 or 1 with this
anomalous or not so is there any quick
questions on this one I can take so
let's just assume that this particular
modeling feature results in a binary or
pickle file of model and we want to
deploy this in the cloud and this
particular model will take the input
data from the sensor and just output
zeros or once whether it's in a bad
state or a good state so the next I
think this is where the major thing is
where the cloud service evaluation
criteria of the 3G CP or in AWS so that
goal is that you want to perform a
preliminary evaluation for deploying
these this pre trained model and we have
a pickle file so pickle is an object
model object file that represents is
already trained and if you can wrap it
with a pickle library of Python then you
can unload this model and perform
predictions on it now what is the prior
knowledge about the services if we take
like assume that we don't have any
knowledge about the service we will rely
heavily on the online documentation that
is available meaning that I will go like
develop custom model for AWS or develop
custom model for GCP that will be like a
first stop for any newbie who wants to
see which service to adopt and this is
what's something we went by we rely
heavily on the online documentation we
spent a couple of days on each of this
service meaning that we want a
high-speed to value not getting too much
into this rabbit hole of things that we
might get into like security rules Iams
etcetera and we admit we acknowledge
that can have been workarounds from what
the solution that I am going to present
or the what we have adopted there can be
workarounds around it it's just that if
given that this is the time and our
skill set I'll be able which cloud
provider is actually the best now within
this
all these cloud providers are kind of
advertised with respect to machine
learning they advertise that ADA
so AWS says okay WH maker you can build
train and deploy models that's there if
we just Google awh maker that's what it
says and same thing with us you are as
you're ml and with GCP it's ml engine so
each of these service providers provide
a machine learning specific kind of
workflow that you can adopt and
corresponding python-based SDKs are also
available which you can do various tasks
like deploying models or deploying
configurations and stuff like that now
the overall deployment workflow is
typically kind of similar in Azure an
AWS GCP but there are subtle changes one
is no matter what you connect a
workspace your local environment to one
of these accounts and now what you do is
that a more it's a model is a kind of a
concept that you need to register a
model to the cloud and you kind of give
information that what is your model name
and once you give that kind of
information you have an allocated space
in the cloud saying that ok it's
expecting this kind of a model will go
in so you register a model it as 0 and
you set up certain configurations which
says which environment your model is
going to run in what are the resources
used and so on and then you deploy it
and similarly for AWS and GCP you have
something like you connect your
workplace workspace but that is a small
difference that now you also need to
actually create a storage in your
accounts respective accounts and you
push your code to this storage once you
push this model files to the storage
then you register a model in your deploy
so that is a small difference in that
kind of a workflow so one next we will
go on to something called deployment
scenarios and here I want to talk about
the fact that as an organization when we
receive some kind of a problem and we
are trying to develop so you
for a use case we start off with simple
models which are of the Shelf available
in a scale own package in Python and
once we kind of make some initial
assessments out of it we kind of do some
more sophisticated workflows and wrap a
scale on around some processing
techniques and then as the code base
becomes more and more sophisticated you
can actually make some like something
like a custom package which can either
be proprietary or it can be like an
open-source package so though as we go
down in the model implementation or the
kinds of modeling libraries that we use
we are increasing our domain specificity
and the sophistication of our workflow
now given that this is what we are going
to do we are going to have three kinds
of models and we will try to fill it up
like in each of this how these cloud
providers actually fare is any quick
question I can let me say that if we
were to use a model with SQL or only SQL
and by this I mean that if we just
unpack this particular component in this
pipeline which is a model predict a
model predict is basically something
like you have an object called model and
you're running a prediction like you're
doing a model dot predict and giving
your input values without doing any kind
of a pre-processing this is the most
simplest case that anyone can do is just
give whatever input it is and give it to
the output so without any pre-processing
how do these cloud services fit the
deploy scenario let's just look at two
codes of deployment one is Azure and AWS
clearly the code does not fit in this
block so that itself is speaks like how
much you actually have to code to get
this done on the other hand if you see
the GCP let's see how easy it is here we
have a bucket name which means that as I
mentioned for Google Cloud you need to
push your model files to a cloud storage
and that's what they call it a bucket
and you give a name to your
okay regions are important because
depending on where the servers are it
can kind of have you can have access to
those particular resources and we give a
model name and this particular fourth
line the gsutil is basically pushing is
creating a bucket in the cloud and we
are using successive quotes to actually
push our code to the cloud and then we
create a model resource and then we
proceed to actually deploy using this
particular G cloud API and what actually
here this is important that all these
cloud providers provide a framework for
these machine learning solutions and
Google cloud for example provides
something called a scikit-learn so it
already has these containerized systems
where it kind of knows that oh it has to
use SK learn based libraries or the
environment and it's expecting that kind
of a model now there are some certain
very important things here is like in
this particular while you're deploying
to the cloud you might you would have
made your model in a local environment
and if that does not necessarily match
the production environment then you can
run into trouble so you have certain
runtime versions in each of this
services and for example Google Cloud
has something called 1.14 and as a user
you must know that what that 1.14
consists like which Python version it is
what are the machine learning libraries
that it contains and so on and as you
can also see there is a Python version
3.5 so this is actually kind of also
important that as a developer you will
be developing codes using the latest
packages but that may not be necessarily
compatible with something that the best
of the cloud solution provides so there
might have to make a modeling decisions
around that that yes I cannot go make my
code in 3.6 I might also need 3.5
compatibility I will just go to the same
equivalent code of deploying a model in
Azure and let's see
AWS for first so the same code for AWS
we make we have a bucket AWS has is
extra step yep
sorry yes so you can use job lip as well
yeah they give typically pickle and
jobless
so that that's where that so that's
right so pickle and job lit by the
typical work flows most of them would
use if you want some kind of a
customization on top of it then things
will start to break so that is where I
want to stress that even for the
simplest case like a scale alone you
might have to then go on to
containerized systems and so on and it
that's so the same GCP bad we saw in
like probably ten lines of code in AWS
it has a similar workflow where you set
up a storage now one thing that I really
found painful was in AWS you need to
explicitly take care of the rules and
security in the credentials and so on
and it's kind of the documentation is
really not that great around it so I
will show you some screenshots of where
I felt problem with but once you make a
cloud storage then you just
tari out all the model files and you
push that model file to the bucket and
once all your modeling files are
available you create a model object in
the cloud and as you can clearly see
that too soon you are actually exposed
to a very low level API compared to what
I showed on GCP where the relevant
information was good enough for my
initial workflow now I'm certainly
exposed to this kind of API where I need
to look back into what the model name
could be what is an execution role a
primary container and like even if
you're exposing stuff like this to your
end user I think it's very important
that an equivalent level of
documentation should also be available
and next we is once you create a model
again you deploy a model is two steps
which is you create something called an
in point configuration which shows which
states that if you were to use a
particular compute resource in the cloud
which one would it be there are multiple
instances they call it like a t2 t1 etc
which basically is how what is the
configuration of my system how much RAM
does it have how much memory does it
have etcetera and variant for example to
be frank I don't know what all traffic
variant name is so that itself is
something now finally create end point
you create an end point so the same
deployment stage in AWS looks like this
now just to showcase quickly on the
azure component the one thing that we
found in Azure is that even though they
expose you a low-level API but it's kind
of a reasonable level to which that you
can do some kind of a customization up
front
meaning that in GCP when I said that you
give a runtime version of 1.14 you are
kind of logged into that ecosystem of
Python being 3.5 and SK scikit-learn
package being 0.2 0.2 but a similar
workflow in Azure suggests that you can
actually set up your own Python
environment through a condor framework
and this is actually pretty helpful
because now even though I'd step 0 you
have been exposed to low-level API it's
not that bad and the other steps kind of
remain the same and it's pretty readable
if you just go through what's happening
so this is where I want to suggest that
GCP gives you a high level API
throughout as you're kind of gives you a
low level API but it's manageable
AWS it gives you very low level API
which is still not manageable assuming
that you're not a power user if the
story can be totally different that if
you are a power user who's well-liked
conversed with all these skills then yes
so this is where I kind of chart it out
in these three columns of easy to
implement as per documentation for a
zero-g CP but AWS clearly not simple and
with respect to AWS we'll come back to
this particular component of how a
simple search of which service to use
actually kind of puts you into you can
use service there you can use service B
you can use service the and it kind of
confusing all the three services make a
very strong assumption that you are
going to call if you are going to invoke
an endpoint in the cloud it is going to
call dot predict so the question then
becomes that if we were to wrap our
module function with some pre-processing
and post-processing how can this dot
function adapt to it so that we can do
some kind of customization tool now I
already discussed about the different
deployment environments that we see so
one of the issues with the AWS
specifically is lack of uniform again
documentation it pushes you towards
containers too soon and this is where I
did a simple search of deploy custom
models on AWS and on the left hand side
you see this kind of a page where it
takes you to AWS and if we read this red
one it kind of starts to tell you you
should do containers and you should have
this is a tutorial on containers and so
on so this is step zero for AWS and if
we dig a bit if we dig a bit deeper into
the code base of sage maker you will
find certain notebooks that people are
made which can take you till one point
of time but then you will soon run into
errors because these notebooks are not
being either adapted to the decent
libraries so one such example is where I
created a s3 bucket in the cloud and I
just tried to push my code into the code
a very simple operation step zero and I
see this error that I do not have
permissions to do so and there is no
documentation that says that what how
you should solve this problem unless as
a diligent user we will go to stack
overflow and we will see this for a
common problem which came three years
eight months ago and still active in
eight months
it's a very recurrent problem even still
and we go up dig further I find that
within the s3 bucket you have something
called the permissions within
permissions you have something called
the bucket policy and once you create
this click this bucket policy you will
come into this thing which is a policy
generator and within this policy
generator now you will be like ok what
the hell is principle what is a RN and
so on and you get you it's it's all this
is solvable if you're a power user but
the same code when I showed in GCP and
azure I was not exposed to this kind of
stuff so this is one pain point now that
that does not mean that not pain points
and other ones there are certain pain
points and for example in Google Cloud I
mentioned that there is the runtime
operation of 1.14 that you provide and
that uses Python 3.5 and a particular
cycle learn now
but consider a scenario where your local
model development uses latest Python
packages but these Google these cloud
providers are not ready for it and you
will run into this error but this is one
example where my SK learn package for
3.5 was not compatible and it just says
that OS : dot linear model dot
underscore rich is not found now if you
dig into the scikit-learn code you will
see that between the zero point two one
and zero point two to the API actually
significantly changed so that's what is
one lesson learned is that no where you
are going to deploy a priority so that
you can make coding decisions around
your production code as well in upfront
so this is again the key takeaways is
the common problem is which service to
use I already discussed move a
production environment and pickle files
must be compatible your production
environment one common thing is that the
ml workflows offered are easy to use for
simple cases because these pack all
these ml workflows that the cloud
providers are given do the simplistic
use cases and any slight going out of
there kind of a comfort zone just really
problematic now GCP was this as there
was AWS I think I already talked that
they give a very high level API but AWS
does not so any many takes on this any
questions around this okay so next
outline is let's take this simple model
and let's say we want to do a
customization that this model should
take some kind of a transformed input
and should transform the output and in
this one I'm doing this entire pipeline
purely through a psychic learn Python
library now one thing that is kind of
good a positive thing is that all
services like Azure and GCP kind of
acknowledge that you might have to do
this operation and give you this
facility a kind of customizations
through some mechanism Azure for example
gives you something called ask old pipe
and score file a score file is basically
where you can wrap this predict function
before and after you can put all your
pieces of code around this and similarly
Google cloud provides a class exposes a
class to you called a predictor class
where you can do the same and for AWS
there was no direct way and it you have
to move to containers and this is the
documentation that acknowledges it
clearly says so and same thing happens
for GCP how would a node for GCP is that
this kind of if you want some
customization in your model prediction
it is in a beta version but it is still
workable and AWS the documentation takes
you to do continuation and this is what
the class actually looks like it's not I
hope it's readable this is my original
Python this is a class where I can
customize my prediction function my
original prediction function was just
something like outputs is model dot
predict but now I can wrap it up with
whatever I want away here and I can do
some kind of post-processing and return
it now the only change that will happen
is how do you communicate that this
particular class should basically this
particular class to be indicated in the
deployment stage so in the deployment
script your Google Cloud everything
remains the same except you just give an
extra argument that there is this
predictor class and that's the
customization is done so without much of
change with single line I got my tasks
to be done no let's I'll just go through
this fast and I would say that let's say
that we have made a very sophisticated
code and this is particularly cold which
we call a DDK anomaly detection toolkit
which has a specific task of doing
anomaly detection in this time series
data my colleague Tyler when gave a talk
about this and these are their some
model description of what it does now
the question is if we want not to use
scikit-learn packages but our own custom
packages how well would it do for sake
of time I will skip this but we can talk
offline about this particular model it
turned out that it was still actually
possible to use custom models through
Azure and GCP from the customizations
that
specifically as the or gave you a score
dot pi and he simply gave you a
predictor class the only thing that I
think I want to reiterate is that when
this ad TK was developed there was a
point where ad TK was three point six
version and then the question becomes
okay you cannot actually curve host this
on these any cloud providers and we made
a three point five compatible ad TK I'm
not saying that it was that was the
decision point but I'm just trying to
say that that the odd production side of
the code can get affected like you might
have to make decision points before of
which Python version your code should be
in and this is the class where my
predictor class just gets affected which
is my outputs is model dot detect
everything remains the same actually and
just for something like if we want more
details about which runtime versions are
compatible with it which ones they have
a very good documentation your one thing
I've noticed I don't know if it's a
coincidence or I don't know why is that
runtime version is same as a tensorflow
version so if I'm using one point one
three or one point one four here it will
be 1 point one four so I'm still not
sure how why they have actually done
that kind of time thing so I'll go to
the final remark is that the
documentation is super important while
we are doing this we need a high-speed
to value and we need easy configurations
of I am rules etc as a data scientist
and allowing customizations by high
level API as much as possible is
preferable that does not mean that we
don't want to go into low level but it's
just that the transition from high level
to low level can be much smoother and
this is where it's like the question
then I think most of my slides like 30%
of the slides will be like there is an
issue with this there's an issue with
that but I would like to end in a
positive note like saying that we were
able to successfully deploy these models
on two of the providers and that's
actually a very positive thing very good
thing and they are very useful services
that we must all use the question is
just then how much do you want to go out
of your comfort zone and
new things and make we make it possible
to do so that's it from my side yeah let
me know any questions questions so yes
even Google Ord has the best experience
and they are both equally important
according to what you how much
customization you need can we get your
slides in notebooks that you show us yes
oh sorry no thanks
I'm a little bit more familiar with AWS
I always get this feeling and GCP so so
between 0 and GCP it's frankly a tough
choice because both would equally easy
to do it's because if you go by pure
number of lines of code that does not
indicate it as long as even if the code
is long but you understand what's
happening then it's fine
I like for us your I really like that at
a very beginning stage they give you
this thing of given anaconda environment
that you want to provide because if you
are used to making a virtual anaconda
environment it becomes an easy to do so
for GCP specifically you'll have to use
a runtime version 1.1 for it's kind of
the other way like you can start off
with something and provide to Gio as
your and they will adhere to it but for
GCP you see what is in 1.1 for you are
zero to it and then it happens so but
both are equally helpful yeah so price
is something where this is like even
really before stage like we we are let's
say price is not a concern and we just
want speed to value because there are
other ways your price can get affected
meaning that if you are really spending
so all your resources and time on a
service that is bad then again that time
has to be mapped to price as well so
once we find this kind of a mapping of
how much time you save then I think the
next step would be that is it still
financially viable to do so do you have
any other impact in terms of the other
side thus a database that you probably
have to make a decision on which
provider you're going to work with is
that also making an
roaming in terms of which service so in
terms of database like word terms of all
the word data for all these equipment is
being strain and where you're storing it
perhaps you're using one of those
services but having having made that
decision later on were impact position
where you're running whether you have to
marry with us your or see gcp or AWS
right right so this is actually those
yeah this is a kind of a tricky thing of
if you want to do storage and databases
it depends upon which setting you are
working and if you're working on as an
organization like for us via you know
sometimes encounter customers who
already have association with a
particular kind of these cloud providers
so if that is the case then yes you
might have to work around with that if
that is not the case if you're looking
for open to use that I did not do that
kind of frankly but I know like Amazon
has their own Google storage overall
documentation in general I really like
Google documentation so it seems you
know if done properly by the admin guide
you know when a user sponsored you know
cluster you don't the user doesn't need
to go around and start tinkering with it
have to do once he spawns the system the
whole clouds that that that environment
knows that this is the user based on his
role he has access to these services and
it's kind of very seamless for doing
with that in mind how you compare among
these three services like which which
one of them is kind of very easy
experiment yep so setting aside the part
of roles as well that is totally valid
because given the same like if you tell
me that deploy AWS instance right now
since for me everything is configured
yes
that part is managed easily now answer
to the question would be I would still
use either a zero-g CP because that the
third criteria the third modeling aspect
deployment scenario where I mentioned
that we have our custom package what is
our take or how easy it is to deploy a
custom package to the cloud this does
not consider roles or AIIMS or anything
and clearly there is no direct way in
AWS because you have to start going to
cuss containers and that kind of a
system so the question then becomes is
are you comfortable with that kind of
how do you is it acceptable for you to
go in that and learn that thing
thank you